an example of a weak base is ammonia
nh3 and ammonia will react with water
and in this reaction water functions as
a bronsted-lowry acid and donates a
proton
to ammonia which functions as a
bronsted-lowry base and accepts a proton
a proton is h plus so if you add on h
plus onto nh3
you form nh4 plus which is the ammonium
ion
and if you take away an h plus from h2o
you form the hydroxide anion which is oh
minus
this reaction comes to an equilibrium so
we have an equilibrium arrow in here
and we can also write an equilibrium
constant expression
so first we look at our products we have
nh4 plus and there's a coefficient of
one in front of it so it'd be the
concentration of nh4 plus raised to the
first power
times the concentration of the other
other product hydroxide which also has a
coefficient of one so it's the
concentration of hydroxide raised to the
first power
divided by the concentration of ammonia
and the coefficient is also one so
that's also raised to the first power
and water is left out of our equilibrium
constant expression
the equilibrium constant k has a
subscript of b which stands for base
and this kb is called the base
ionization constant or the base
dissociation constant ammonia is a weak
base which means it only partially
ionizes in water
and if it only partially ionizes at
equilibrium there's going to be a small
amount of products
and a large amount of reactants
therefore looking at the equilibrium
constant expression the numerator is
going to be very small compared to
the denominator so with a small
numerator and a large denominator that
means that the kb
value for a weak base will be less than
one
let's look at a few examples of weak
bases here's the dot structure for
ammonia and notice how
ammonia has a nitrogen with a lone pair
of electrons that's capable of accepting
a proton
a proton is h plus so if we add an h
plus on to nh3
we form nh4 plus which is
the ammonium ion and it's the conjugate
acid to
ammonia so think about this lone pair of
electrons that i circled here picking up
a proton to form
this bond if we replace the hydrogen
with what's called a methyl group ch3
we form a new weak base called
methylamine
like ammonia methylamine has a nitrogen
with a lone pair of electrons it's
capable
of accepting a proton so if methylamine
picks up a proton
it forms the methyl ammonium ion
both ammonia and methylamine are
examples of neutral substances
however a weak base doesn't have to be
neutral if we look at the hypochlorite
anna nclo minus if the hypochlorite
anion picks up a proton let's say this
lone pair of electrons in the oxygen
picks up a proton we would form the
hypochlorous
we would form hypochlorous acid and
hypochlorous acid is the conjugate
acid to hypochlorite so these are three
examples of weak
bases which we can tell by looking at
their kb values at 25 degrees celsius
notice they all have kb values less than
one
however the higher the kb value the
higher the equilibrium concentration of
hydroxide ion
and therefore the stronger the base so
out of these three
weak bases the one with the higher kb
value is the most
basic so looking at these three values
again
the kb value for methylamine is the
highest
of the three so it's the strongest base
of the three although all three
are considered to be weak let's do a
calculation with a weak base
let's say we have a 0.14 molar solution
aqueous solution of ammonia at 25
degrees celsius and our goal is to
calculate
the concentration of hydroxide ions in
solution
and also the ph of the solution at 25
degrees celsius
so first we're going to calculate the
equilibrium concentration of hydroxide
ions and to help us do that we're going
to use an ice table
where i stands for the initial
concentration c is the change in
concentration and e
is the equilibrium concentration the
initial concentration of ammonia is 0.14
molar so we can put that
in on our ice table and if we assume
that ammonia hasn't ionized at all yet
the initial concentrations of
ammonium and hydroxide ions would both
be
zero next we think about some of the
ammonia ionizing and we don't know how
much
so we write minus x under ammonia for
the change
when nh3 gains a proton it turns into
nh4 plus
and the mole ratio of ammonia to
ammonium is one to one
therefore if we write minus x for
ammonia we must write
plus x for ammonium and the hydroxide
ion also has a 1 as a coefficient in the
balanced equation
therefore it would also be plus x in our
ice table
so the equilibrium concentration of
ammonia would be 0.14
minus x so let's write that in there
0.14 minus x
for ammonium it would be 0 plus x which
is just
x and for hydroxide it would also be 0
plus
x which is just x the next step is to
write out the equilibrium constant
expression for the ionization of ammonia
which we've already talked about
and since the concentrations in our
equilibrium constant expression are
equilibrium concentrations
we can go ahead and plug in the
equilibrium concentrations of the
ammonium ion
the hydroxide ion and ammonia into our
equilibrium constant expression
we also need to plug in 4k b for ammonia
at 25 degrees celsius
here's our equilibrium constant
expression with everything plugged
in and our goal is to solve for x
because x represented the equilibrium
concentration of hydroxide ions
however if we solve for x now we would
get a quadratic equation
so to simplify the math we're going to
use an approximation
we're going to say that 0.14 minus x
is approximately equal to 0.14
the reason why we can make this
approximation is because the kb
value for ammonia is quite small which
means that ammonia doesn't ionize very
much at all which tells us the
equilibrium concentration of hydroxide
ions
will be a very small number and if x is
a really small number
compared to 0.14 0.14 minus x is just
approximately equal to 0.14
so instead of writing 0.14 minus x we
can just write in 0.14
so now we solve for x and we find that x
is equal to 1.6 times 10 to the negative
third molar which is the equilibrium
concentration of hydroxide ions our goal
is to calculate the ph of our solution
and first we could find the poh because
poh is equal to the negative log of the
concentration of hydroxide ions
so the negative log of 1.6 times 10 to
the
negative third is equal to
2.80
and at 25 degrees celsius the ph plus
the poh is equal to 14.00
so we could plug in the poh into our
equation and solve for the ph
and we would find the ph of our solution
is equal to
11.20
and this makes sense because we have a
basic solution so the ph should be
greater than
7. finally to make sure that we can use
our approximation
let's find the percent ionization for
our weak base
to calculate the percent ionization of
ammonia
we take x which you could think about as
the concentration of ammonia that
ionized or you could think about it as
the equilibrium concentration of
hydroxide ions
and we divide x by the initial
concentration of ammonia
and multiply by 100 to get a percent
ionization
so for this problem x is equal to 1.6
times 10 to the negative
third molar so we go ahead and plug that
in here so 1.6 times 10 to the negative
third molar
and the initial concentration of ammonia
was equal to 0.14
molar so molar cancels out and we end up
with
a percent ionization of 1.1
percent once you calculate the percent
ionization you need to think about the
five
percent rule and the five percent rule
says if your percent ionization is less
than five percent
it's okay to use the approximation so in
our case our percent ionization was one
point one percent which is less than
five percent so it's okay to say that
0.14 minus
x is approximately equal to 0.14 because
with such a low percent ionization
x is a really small value compared to
0.14
however if you get a percent ionization
greater than five percent
you can't use the approximation and you
need to use the quadratic equation
to calculate x finally when we
calculated our equilibrium concentration
of hydroxide ions
we only considered the ionization of
ammonia
it's true that the autoionization of
water would produce
a small amount of hydroxide ions in
solution however that concentration is
extremely small compared to
the concentration of hydroxide ions from
the ionization of ammonia therefore we
ignore the contribution of hydroxide
ions
from the autoionization of water in our
calculations